si la limpieza va de mano con la
devoción el río yamuna es la excepción
este río sagrado de india está cubierto
por espuma tóxica algo que según los
activistas se debe al vertido ilegal de
residuos industriales ya las aguas
residuales sin tratar los funcionarios
del gobierno en delhi llevan años
comprometidos con la limpieza del río
pero la espuma tóxica vuelve cada año y
algunos vecinos están hartos
formenty que sigue nation
el gobierno no escucha a nadie viene de
visita se devuelven y no pasa nada la
contaminación es la causa principal de
las enfermedades toda el agua está llena
de productos químicos puro pone a vapor
térmico al capone mientras la
contaminación interrumpía el suministro
de agua en algunas partes de la ciudad
algunos fieles estaban decididos a
bañarse en ella a pesar de todo con
motivo de un festival hindú el diwali
dedicado al sol
y no pasará nada malo el dios del sol no
dejará que ocurra nada malo está agua
parece sucia pero es sagrada fue vital
para mí
pero incluso lejos de las orillas del
río no hay forma de escapar de la
contaminación ya que toda la ciudad está
envuelta en un espeso manto de niebla
tóxica el fuerte descenso de la calidad
del aire se debe a la quema de residuos
por parte de los agricultores ya las
personas que celebran el igual y además
las temperaturas más bajas impiden que
el aire contaminado suba y se disipe en
la atmósfera